uh when i think about you in sex in the
city you think you got that role because
in real life you are this wild sexual
person or something no i had done uh a
film called live nude girls and i think
from a very early age films like porkies
and police academy and mannequin you
know for me as an actress my where i
really live is in the theater but you
can't make a living in the theater no so
i mean if you look at my resume it's
like two different actresses one is like
this theater career which is very
classical and the other one is like
these crazy movies that i was doing but
i was really paying my rent right i
didn't come from i'm a blue collar girl
you know i i didn't want to go back to
waitressing and slinging hash i wanted
to continue even you know in a movie
that i felt well it's not exactly what i
want to do right that's going to pay my
rent for the next day sure no it's a
business
absolutely what did you mean in your
email to me
you wrote me an email and said you're
going to tell me something about the
porkies that i never knew well that was
it actually it came to me bob clark took
me to lunch and i had done tribute with
him with jack lemmon which was nominated
for academy awards and then he said i
have this little movie which is going to
change you know how people perceive you
and i went yeah yeah yeah yeah right
and how was that and then he he sent it
to me and all my agents said you can't
you can't do this movie and i said yeah
i can't do this movie but i also can't
pay my rent right and i thought you know
this movie will do well and it'll
probably do drive-ins and i remember
driving my car down sunset boulevard it
was living in ally very unhappily at the
time lonely oh depressed and i came
across this huge mother freaking poster
of porkys and the first name was my name
i was like
were you upset about that because you
probably thought porky's was a probably
a [ __ ] movie nobody knew what it was
in some ways it was way before its time
it was a fantastic movie and yet
probably at the time you said i'm a
serious actress i shouldn't be doing
something called portuguese but you know
you probably thought it was the end of
your career porky people thought it was
the end of my career yes right and
meanwhile it's it's one of the things
that you are known for and praised for
yes
groundbreaking movie but at the time
they thought it was a piece of bunk i
mean they went on and on now this isn't
you know uh compared with other films
that were out at the time like animal
house they were saying this is a frat
boy movie this is stupid was it hard for
you to get work after porky's was it was
it like oh she's in that shitty porky it
was easy to get work like porkies like
police academy because you're associated
with a hit so then you go on this trail
and this other trail that you were on
with movies like tribute and ticket to
heaven where you're nominated for awards
and you're going that direction suddenly
michelle pfeiffer is taking all those
rules and i can't get near them because
you were in porky because i was
sexualized in that way